today's topic we got skippy but
this is skippy from early 2000's
he did a show called blind date
so the whole reason i'm going out
tonight is there is this girl
named rachel that i actually uh met at
my church group about
a year ago and i'm going to ask her out
tonight
there's a share concert next week and
i'm really
hoping that she'll agree to go with me
as my date
growing up in utah when it comes to
girls and when it comes to what comes
natural to people at our age
we avoid almost all of it or at least i
do
anyway so uh i've never had sex before
i'm a 24 year old virgin if you can
imagine that
and so uh just trying to save myself for
that one special lady
hi are you are you sure it's okay
like yeah okay okay just go for ice
cream yeah just real quick
it's already awkward
this is what i say when i respect skippy
he's been this way
for 20 years
god hey is this okay huh is this okay
just wanna yeah just oh man wow
okay corey
from our ward asked you out last night
yes is that generally the baffler
you know what you know this it's ja rule
and asante
where is ja jaws
do you like him like that i think i do
really yeah yeah yeah the first
40 seconds and this man's already
getting cooked
this is brutal hey here's the right if
you are into someone
as you know she went on a date with
somebody else who she may be into
don't spend the whole day asking about
him is going to go ahead just go on this
date and try to act right and then maybe
she will be more into you keep it moving
you're already on the date
classic
[Music]
let's like go up and like look at
the view over salt lake have you been up
there before where am i
yeah near enzyme peak is that cool
so you kissed boys before yeah
you like kissing boys
yeah he's a two honey for you so you
kissed boys before
you like kissing boys what part of the
boys do you like kissing
where tell me how do you like
show me using tongue your tongue show me
why you're coming
show me you're not kissing boys i had
one
i was born a boy burner boy
please yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
rachel hey scott i brought you up here
for a reason
okay i have flowers for you
oh wow is this avril lavigne
hey boys what you're looking for
somebody else like everyone else you're
trying to be cool
you look like a fool to me
[Applause]
i butchered the lyrics but hey let's
keep going next part
okay i've got something for you
look at her face man if they found this
tape
in a ditch do you think they'd be like
she's definitely
dead they'd be looking for a body for
sure bro she's already looking like can
anyone see where we are right now
but these are little toy boats let's
call this
a friendship okay
and this is a friendship too right
and we've been you know
like sailing these little friendships
you know for a while and stuff like that
like a year right yep what didn't you
say okay
so we're sailing the friendship but
there's another boat that's in the
harbor
you ready for this huh i don't know huh
this boat
is called a relationship
oh my god
so
uh
wow this one takes the cake this one is
i'm not picking up oh i feel sick
oh my god let's finish this i think
there's a way
to go from a friendship to a
relationship
and in order to get to the relationship
we have to share things you ready for
this
did you see her face are you ready for
do that again are you ready for this
you see this do you see this
okay it says share yeah there's a shared
concert coming up
and what i attempted to do not so
smoothly was bring you up here
and ask you if you'll go with me to the
share concert
it's on wednesday
[Music]
i just want to let you know right now i
i think of you
it's just a friend and scott i think
you're a great guy
but
[Music]
is it short fat white and desperate in
here or is it just me what the heck i'm
just like feeling so awkward
did he say is it short fat
white and desperate
it's crazy that at 24 skippy seemed to
have more self-awareness
than he does today i'm sorry scott
that's okay we're still friends
[Music]
awkward end of the night i'm just not
sure
i just yeah sure perhaps not
you sure it's okay sure okay thank you
you know i'm not even sure right now if
i'm totally going to the share
concert with her i tend to think we're
probably
not but all in all i still feel pretty
good i mean
i'm still the best looking guy in the
car
oh my god oh
no i'm sorry but no i can't do it
i can't do it i really tried
he's been like this for 25 years so if
he was ever going to learn he would have
learned by now
yes sometimes you gotta admit it some
people just uh they're not gonna learn
they don't want to change
they don't want to do you think he
doesn't want him he doesn't want to
he doesn't want to because he's too
concerned with his own needs and so he's
not thinking about self-improvement
how are you 24 in better shape
probably making the same amount of money
then at 44 you're still working as a
pizza delivery driver in worse shape
and then thinking you're going to do
better and your game hasn't gotten any
better you got more desperate
you haven't made an effort so uh that's
all i got but hey you know what i'm
saying
skippy do your thing you know i mean
what thing you know what i mean what
what thing
the cringe thing it is a thing it's a
thing
didn't say it was a successful team i
back down okay i back down all right i'm
gonna give it to you okay
so that's all there is to it tell us
what you guys think
[Music]
oh